so it's like your mama's dream was for
you to be the UK's first black prime
minister right yeah yeah if you let her
down you feel disappointment 100 because
that was the route that I was on I was
like a super academic uh kid in school
and then like that's cool for some
reason just decided to U-turn into
acting and and for her it must have been
insanely surprising though because it's
like suddenly your kid just might as
well have told you he wants to be a
clown and go to clown school and and
yeah and um and yeah but you know I went
to drama school and and once you know we
started on our way with with acting she
yeah she was insanely supportive so my
thing was always I'm not going to be the
UK's first black prime minister but I
might play him in a show one day I know
that's I'm so curious serious like
that's such a cool thing to to be active
in like as a kid like what what do you
think made you pivot into acting
um I mean I had some really dope
teachers but I I don't know I think
there's something about you know like uh
being a kid with a funny accent I came
from Nigeria and there's something about
performing that um is a way to you know
you can hide in your characters I guess
and so like that became a thing where it
was like I didn't feel so isolated when
I was a part of a company or or you know
doing plays or hiding in a character and
um and so yeah that kind of just became
my Escape in a little way and then it
became the thing where I was like if I
am doing law every day for the rest of
my life I'm going to be pretty miserable
but if I'm doing this thing then I might
not be that sad so so yeah well I can
tell your mom is super proud that's good
I'm a mama yeah you're proud anytime
your kid like finds themselves or finds
themselves how many are in there finds
himself and like really loves what
they're doing and is Passion about it
that's cool
I've moved out like you're not gonna
afford to live on myself we can afford
to do this my brother and I I'd be
eating like bread and water every day
but oh my God I lived on Ramen Ramen yo
have you ever tried indomie it's like
Nigerian ramen noodles no I'm gonna find
a way to like grab you some and get
yourself I mean you probably don't need
yeah yeah I try everything
traveling like all over the world so
so I'll try anything I won't love
everything but I'll try it let me know
how you feel it yeah I want you gonna
yeah I'm gonna get you something to me
okay I'm willing to do this
that was a given man I'm like I'm gonna
bring it to impact
gets into me automatically perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you